you're so incorrect are you a Muslim as
well yeah alhamdulillah okay okay what
did um what did I say that was incorrect
you said the prophet prophets recognized
your lord I.E the free and one God
concept no they didn't neither did
Abraham preach your religion or neither
he preached Jesus as God or yeah or the
Trinity all right you're not abrahamic
Faith Jews and Muslims don't not
recognize you as Abraham and we regard
you as pagans I like you I like you a
lot you're a pagan you're a pagan M I
got it I got it I got you I got you I
got you yeah I got
so where do you get my friend let's
let's have a conversation let's have a
conversation where do you get the
teachings of the prophets from where do
you get it it all comes from um well I'm
being a Muslim I'm meant to listen to
what what is T to me right through the
Quran that's not what I mean if you
wanted to learn what Abraham taught
where would you go you can't because
those books are corrupted the previous
scriptures so how do you know what
Abraham taught or didn't teach if you
can't go to his own words his own
teachings how would I know because look
something as concise as the Quran with
his scientific approach and everything
that comes with it scientific yeah what
do what does science have to do with
what I'm asking about I'm simply asking
I'm just telling you because that is the
truth to me that's what it is
so you know my examples is it when you
say the truth to me that means that you
are giving me a subjective opinion which
with all due respect I don't care about
what I care about is the fact of the
matter and when you tell me by fact that
Abraham did not believe in the same God
that I believed in and that Abraham
didn't teach or Express belief in the
concept of a Triune God or a
multi-personality
that means that you know what Abraham
taught you have access to what Abraham
taught show me where I don't I don't
have anything to hand that I can show
you just like you can't show me you
can't show me what Adam believed you
can't show that to me no just to be
specific just to be specific why why you
why you just why do you have to have
this approach
towards I'll tell you why I have to have
this approach from
your I'll tell you why I have this
approach towards a Muslim like you the
reason why I have this approach towards
a Muslim like you is because a Muslim
like you starts off with no because you
Abraham didn't believe this Abraham
believed this Abraham didn't believe
this Moses didn't believe this prophets
didn't believe this they believe this
you're not st stop stop so when a Muslim
like you pops up on my panel and starts
off like that the old only thing I ask
is how do you know and you crumble
immediately I'm not crumbling okay
because I question to you the same
methodology you appli don't waste my
time let's not waste each other's time
look I'm not I'm not I'm not having an
argument with you I'm just going to say
something let's honor each other's
because I heard you make these ludicrous
claims to us ludicrous okay ludicrous
show me where show me how show me you
can't just go and he doesn't doesn't
functioning show me what Abraham
believed about God show me from his what
he taught now you show me you show me I
to do you admit that you don't okay hold
on hold on hold on just be real you're
making this ludicrous claim you prove it
because I know what I spoke to Jews and
they confirm what I am telling you but
they don't confirm what you are talking
about because they told those Jews that
you're talking those that you're talking
believe Jesus is the Messiah sorry do
those Jews that you're talking to
believe that Jesus is the Messiah they
don't accept Jesus I know I I get that
wait so who's right out of you guys they
are waiting they are waiting for the
Messiah I I didn't ask all that yeah who
is right out of you guys who's right out
of us guys so I I believe Jesus is you
know he's going to have a second coming
yeah don't ask you believe that Jesus is
the m Messiah the Jews who you spoke to
don't believe Jesus is the Messiah yeah
that's all right listen to me there's
two approaches right like you don't Jews
don't accept Jesus you don't accept
Muhammad sallu alaihi wasallam do you
get me every time there's been a
progression I'm going to give you one
last chance serial come on brother we're
old enough to be able to do this you're
respectful and I take that I'm trying
I'm trying not to go the other I'm
trying to be cool still but you're not
let me call that and I'll come back to
you I'll come back to you yeah well well
we're right here where does so you say
that he's not the you say he's the
Messiah Jew say he's not the Messiah
which one of you guys have it right we
confirm what was revealed before so you
confirm what was revealed before wait
what was revealed before you know with
the previous scriptures right what
previous scriptures IE the in what is
that what is that so you know these
scriptures are being corrupted over the
years so how do you even know what's in
them because you can tell you can tell I
can tell by I I give you some as some
example right show me this in that says
Jes that's like that's like you that's
like you all right show me the Torah
where it says Jesus is the Messiah God
logic you come up with a you're
Christian right so you come up original
Quran only Christian all right so you
know you come after after the Jews how
are you going to go and explain to a Jew
suppose I wasn't here as
no don't waste my time trying to ask me
another question you need to answer you
still have answer answer you answer
youing that to you you can't tell
me you refer refer to what was revealed
before but it's gone how do you refer to
what was revealed before if it's gone
you don't have it how do you refer to it
you can tell by it's corruption and I'll
tell you why because you don't because
you don't submit to the laws to your
scripture you are given the same laws as
us what laws
the laws like woman to Adorn the head
scar which is I hijab wait wait a second
where is where is that not all to where
is that that's in your Bible wait so my
Bible is what was revealed previously
and you can still find it today I'm I'm
going to pull it up for you so is my
Bible what was revealed previously yeah
the Old Testament he say
oh amazing all right this is what I want
you to do you said the old Testament can
you show me one single verse in the Old
Testament where it tells the woman to
cover up show you I'll show you by the
way what do you think of Paul I think I
don't know much about him but I think
that he can many 100 years later than
Jesus and he's claiming to be his
Apostle and I think brought up with
something new um uh I think Constantine
was the one who introduced the church
that's okay I just asked about Paul
that's I didn't want to distract you too
much okay all right cool cool cool keep
searching so Paul came a few hundred
years after Jesus changed up
Christianity a bit came with new things
no problem okay just wanted to know all
right so this is something from the
First Baptist the First Baptist Church
this is their website the Bible does
indeed the that woman are supposed to
wear head coverings what's the verse I'm
going to find the verse this is pretty
clear Paul makes in Corinthians 11 1 11
that in church in worship woman are
supposed to wear head covering yeah Paul
said that but I thought Paul came and
changed it and came 100 years after
Jesus every man who
prays okay you know I'm just going to
I'm going to look for more because I'm
I'm I'm sure there's more verses than
that right show show me show me the Old
Testament passage that says women have
to cover up because so far you've quoted
Paul who supposedly came hundreds of
years after Jesus and changed things
that was taught so it seems to me if
Paul is teaching that women need to be
covered up that wasn't taught previously
and Paul changed that shame on Paul
right for changing it to they have to be
covered sh on Paul right Genesis
2465 records the view as a feminine
emblem of modesty so it's a right just
like the Muslim woman of do can you show
me the law in the Old Testament where
women have to be covered in the Old
Testament okay just hold on sh on Paul
for changing the law that women have to
be covered it used to be that they
didn't have to be covered and now thanks
to Paul women have to be covered shame
on Paul all right so first the first um
part that I get is the AI bit on the
results here so it says yes believing
woman in the Old Testament are era
Warhead coverings passages in the Bible
that indicate this include Genesis
2465 numbers 518 Song of Solomon 57
Susanna Susanna 131 to 132 and Isaiah
472 yeah so these are the passages in
there but you know like hey I'm GNA go
through some Bible verses if I can find
any yeah CK do you do you know what I
asked I didn't I didn't ask I didn't ask
to show me examples of women who wore
head coverings I said show me the law in
the Old Testament cuz that's what you
said show me the law that women must
wear head coverings in the Old Testament
that's what I asked for not examples of
women wearing head coverings but no
these are passages in the Bible That's
what I'm saying to you 2465 Genesis yeah
it does say the woman are to Ador
headscarf yeah read read the verse and
say that women are to are to wear head
head headscarves where does it say that
in Genesis you spare with me no worries
all right so he says yeah you you
correct there yeah yeah it says look but
this what the just come out of here hold
on just beay with me so all right so
2465 says and asked the servant who is
that man in the field coming to meet us
yeah he's my master the Serv so she took
her view and covered herself so when she
was in going into the presence of men
she had to to take a V and cover herself
where does it say that she had to do
that it says here right yeah where does
it say that that's what she had didn't
say she had to she did do it oh very
good so it was compulsory it was
compulsory where does it say that where
does where does it say that it's
compulsory for her to have covered her
head no it doesn't say that it says she
took her view and covered herself so now
so it was by her own it was by her own
choice on her own whim that she chose to
cover her head right no why would you do
why would you do that could be cultural
that culturally that's what they used to
do but nowhere do you see that it's
commanded that the women are to cover
themselves correct cover their heads
right I believe it was they it was
compulsory that they had to wear yeah
where what scripture says that what
scripture in the Old Testament says it's
compulsory for them to cover their heads
just B with me I'm find some passages
can I just can I just help you yeah it
doesn't exist man it's not there it
doesn't exist it never was compulsory it
was never commandment the only time you
see this as a commandment is in Paul's
writings who comes according to you 100
a few hundred years after
Jesus change the law change what Jesus
taught and change what the proph you me
to you're me
to you're done you're done Corinthians
116 oh my God the wife will not cover
her head then she should cut her hair
short but it is disg grateful for a wife
to cut her hair or shave her head let
her cover her head cover her head you
got me wait wait what is is Corin
Corinthians his Old Testament isn't it
yeah that's what I'm talking about oh my
gosh and you know what do me this quick
favor okay can you do me this quick
favor because I don't want you to leave
that tab can you open another Tab and
can you put who wrote Corinthians just
really quick ackowledge I acknowledge
it's the Old Testament yeah ackn
knowledge and what you're talking about
is you know you don't have to rely upon
the Old Testament no no no no we do we
we follow the Old Testament but just put
it in put it in real quick who wrote
Corinthians who wrote Corinthians the
all the Apostle Paul wrote the first
letter of Paul to the Corinthians and
the second letter of Paul to the
Corinthians which I thought wait so Paul
was in the Old Testament writing before
Jesus well this is what it says Paul uh
the Apostle Paul oh sorry um it's blurry
can you see it properly now see I can
see it yeah the Apostle Paul wrote the
first letter of Paul to the Corinthians
of Paul to the Corinthians and the
second letter of Paul to the Corinthian
which are both books in the New
Testament wait I thought you said there
in the Old Testament yeah it's New
Testament so you know hey you told you
see the thing is this this is where your
misunderstanding is you said you said I
was done you said oh you're done you're
done yeah you are because because it
does say that you have to wear a head
scuff but you said I was done didn't you
you are because it does say that you
have to wear a head SCU in the New
Testament well if that's the New
Testament you know then it is okay so
let me get this straight so in the New
Testament Paul who comes a few hundred
years after Jesus according to you who
changed the teachings of Jesus and
changed the teachings of the prophets
changed the religion wrote laws himself
he's not inspired by God according to
you right he's not a messenger he's not
a prophet so he's writing stuff his own
self and changed the law from not having
to wear head coverings to it being
mandatory I not that's what I tried to
believe at first but since it says
Corinthians you know Apostle Paul wrote
the first letter of Paul to the
Corinthians in the second letter of Paul
to the Corinthians right it's just
confirming that Corinthians but why why
would he include it into the Corinthians
as a as a law you understand me so so is
so is Corinthians being shown and
brought to us by a messenger of God
you Paul a messenger of God that can
give us law no I don't believe he's a
messenger of God no so then what he said
is not a law then right no he's passed
on the law and who is he to say passed
on the law but you said no you said he
changed you said he changed the teach
all right you this is what I don't
understand you saying that these laws
are non applicable to you now nowadays
because Paul came over and he basically
changed everything right no you no you
said that you said you said that you
said I I F I refer back to the previous
scriptures I said what is that you said
new test doesn't your doesn't your it's
in your scriptures
it's says that that women are supposed
to cover up you didn't know the
Corinthians was actually a written by
Paul but I didn't even know that I was
thinking it's an Old Testament you
understand me this man don't even don't
even know what just happened to he
either he does and he's that stupid or
he doesn't even get what just happened
to him either that brother is that
stupid either you're that dumb and what
just happened to you went over your head
I don't even know if there's an ore
what's the ore is there an ore either
he's that dumb that he missed what just
happened what's the ore I don't even
have an ore there is no or you're just
that dumb you're that stupid that you
missed what just happened to you